escorted me down into the women's board
down into the next part of my life I
passed one cell all the people like
sardines on top of each other and
remember things are so out of place
muscle there was a woman she's kind of
antsy and the policeman says this is
cool this cuckoo dead prison then she
was convicted for killing her husband
and she was sentenced to hang I'm not
supposed to live next door to someone
who's supposed to be dying hmm
the depression just got worse puke
yellow walls on every side weighing me
down it was just a sad sad place
so I finally get the call that there's a
visitor it's so the gentleman from the
embassy is is actually there to see me
my heart kind of jumped for does like
excellent this is huge for me now they
have to let me go I'm kind of bouncing
all the way down the walkway to get to
the office
this my ticket out who's gonna who can
help me out and I'm like okay so let's
let's discuss how I'm gonna get out of
here how are we gonna get out of here
he's unnerving ly calm and not catching
my level of energy Miami's Jesus um yeah
miss McCord I'm sorry there's really
nothing we can do to help you in this
regard I'm getting really sick like my
mouth is like starting to water and I'm
just feel like this is this is not
happening but he looks I mean he says
there's nothing we can do to intervene
on your behalf except to ensure that
you're not being starved or abused to
other no custody it was about two or
three weeks before my birthday that's it
I will kill myself before I will spend
another day beyond my birthday and here
you have to get me out of here miss
McCord I'm sorry there's nothing we can
do to help you
he's basically crushed my whole mental
facade that I'm I'm actually gonna be
able to be able to get out of this and I
could be facing years my life death like
cuckoo
I was broken I was trapped I was in
prison
the next day I woke up this woman comes
by I'll show she basically gave me a
tour of the ward well it's a cuckoo just
kind of starts laying it all out
breaking it all down for me this is how
it works all it says a lot bully none
evil it was in charge and who did what
and what's the different outfits people
were wearing were the people around me
were trying to be nice but there wasn't
the same as family one night they took
cuckoo out this was gonna be the night
that they they executed her
I was really strange because I mean I
seen her everyday I talked to her
when they actually hung the person they
turned the lights off and they turned it
back on to let you know that it was it
actually happened so we're in our cells
and the lights went off was so strange
it was so sad and I heard someone died
and when the cells kind of cry out it
was one more nail in the coffin of the
reality that they carry out the
sentences they gave you it whatever they
sentenced me with I'm gonna have to do
it